monsieur fait rien merci nous accueillir
jour chez vous dans votre cuisine pour
parle un peu de pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
oui ce qu'on cherche à savoir avec vous
c'est concrètement comment ça se
manifeste dans votre cas vous en tant
que restaurateurs et chefs d'entreprise
pour moi je vais dire la situation
devient critique est alarmant même plus
de bon sens je fais partie malgré tout
des privilégiés privilégié parce qu'on
est une grande institution à montréal au
québec et au canada ce qu'on fait partie
des grandes tables du monde donc un
circuit incontournable pour les foodies
manger du monde du monde des jeunes
filles des jeunes gens du monde entier
qui veulent venir travailler chez nous
malheureusement on n'arrive pas à les
faire venir
donc on a un besoin criant de main
d'oeuvre hautement qualifiée chez nous
dans ce restaurant et on n'arrive pas le
combler le résultat c'est que y'a une
perte d'activité financière pour nous
qui les marges de profit qui sont en
fait quoi où habituellement on avait
toujours une diversification de revenus
avec un service traiteur en période de
festival comme cela cette année ans
occulter les feux d'artifice à la ronde
de cette année on a dû décliner c'était
quand même tous les mercredis tous les
samedis où on servait 200 400 personnes
et vous avez décliné précisément à cause
de la question d'améliorer torride parce
que il me faut quand même 30 sa trente
deux cuisiniers tous les jours dans mon
établissement c'est fou ça ferait le
bonheur de tellement de dizaines de
restaurants ici à montréal mais j'arrive
pas en avoir plus pour faire des
activités connexes
donc je me passe de ce revenu que
j'aimerais fortement besoin pour payer
mes dettes également au niveau de la
santé physique mois depuis le 1er
janvier qu'on a ouvert ce restaurant
sincèrement vous pouvez le demander à
n'importe quelle personne qui travaille
chez moi en salle comme en cuisine
j'ai pas réussi à prendre une journée de
repos depuis le mois de janvier depuis
le mois de janvier ça fait plus de six
mois et demi sept mois j'ai pris trois
petites soirées à partir de 10
non pas que je ne veux pas j'ai toujours
eu le coeur à l'ouvragé qu'on fait ce
métier avec amour passionnel à 18 heures
par jour mais de 8 heures du matin
jusqu'à une heure du matin je suis dans
mon entreprise dans ma maison c'est mon
régale c'est ma passion
mais physiquement c'est sûr qu'il va
m'arriver quelque chose si j'arrive pas
à trouver cette relève est donc la
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre elle s'est
installée instauré au fil des années
vous l'avez constaté meslin sentez-vous
vrai on attend on a atteint un plateau
haut niveau vraiment illégal et là je
pense qu'on est dans la sirène d'alarmé
qui a déjà sonné l'année dernière mais
je pense qu'il n'y a pas eu de prise de
conscience
et s'il n'y a pas un réveil un sursaut
gouvernementales qui se fait à la forte
provincial qu'au fédéral dans les
prochains mois à venir il va y avoir
mais des faillites
énorme moi j'ai la souffrance au
téléphone du matin au soir donné
consoeur de mes confrères chef
d'entreprise chef de cuisine à travers
toute la province et en région n'en
parle même pas qu'ils m'appellent un
pleur de me dire qu'ils n'ont plus de
cuisinier certains vont perdre leur
entreprise parce que c'est pas qu'il
manque de clients ils ont leurs clients
mais n'ont pas le personnel pour les
servir à la fois c'est une catastrophe
moi ça me fait saigner le coeur en tant
que kimi grand que je mets tout mon
amour pour le québec et les gens me le
rendent
mais quand je reçois des touristes du
monde entier qui viennent chez moi le la
cuisine est ouverte ils viennent me
parler
tous me disent à quel point le service
est lamentable c'est négliger ils n'ont
pas une belle prestation de touristique
parce qu'ils sentent ce cri alarmant de
maunder ferait le plus de clients le
sang le sang élevé le d'oise
donc c'est pas bon c'est pas bon pour le
tourisme du québec mais vous continuez
malgré toi recevoir un nombre assez
important de s'aimer alors moi je fais
partie des privilégiés
les jeunes gens qui veulent venir de
france hautement qualifiés ou d'espagne
du portugal d'angleterre
on les empêche quasiment devenir je
reçois personnellement 40 cv par jour
je vais vous le montrer sur mon
ordinateur deux jeunes gens à travers
les châteaux des grandes tables du monde
qui veulent venir travailler chez nous
et il se joint à la bureaucratie scène
s'apprend minimum deux mois et demi
trois mois voir des fois cinq mois un
départ à l'étranger ça se prépare
on peut pas dire à quelqu'un je te mets
sur le stand by du bon vouloir du
gouvernement pour venir
mon père était vigneron dans le sud de
la france j'ai grandi dans un village de
100 habitants
quand venait le moment des vendanges il
n'y avait pas les gens des alentours
quitter leur job pour venir amassé
nord-isère les lignes on avait droit à
des permis de travail temporaire
permettant de faire venir des espagnols
des portugais je comprends pas comment
le québec le canada n'arrive pas à
s'organiser avec des permis temporaires
pour nous permettre à nous en
restauration hôtellerie de combler tous
ses membres
mais les chefs d'entreprise les gens
comme vous les propriétaires de
restaurants ce qui est quelque chose que
vous pouvez faire pour la rétention très
personnelle ça c'est sans salaire est ce
que c'est possible pour moi ici notre
philosophie c'est travailler dans un
esprit familial parce que c'est une
famille notre maison on appelle en
respirant seulement une maison de son
passe plus de temps ici qu'un autre
maison donc pour moi mais avant tout ça
passe par la reconnaissance le respect
le salaire c'est l'évolution si de
chacun de se sentir en vie donc chez moi
j'ai décidé depuis bien longtemps
notre que ce soit la planche il
travaille pas au salaire minimum que ce
soit en cuisine faille à 20 dollars de
l'heure parce que vous m'avez vous le
permettre en tant que chef d'entreprise
j'ai des gens qui ont peut-être pas du
tout danger décidé de augmenter un petit
peu le prix de même menu pour augmenter
le prix des salaires mais au fil à sion
on augmente les prix pour les clients
n'avez vous pas peur justement des pères
9 et de les faire déserter resté indécis
effectivement effectivement parce qu'en
augmentant la facture il ya des clients
qui vont jouer le prix de la concurrence
maintenant faut savoir où on veut se
diriger pour moi il n'y a aucun
compromis sur la qualité
il faut qu'il y ait une conscience de ce
que le québec m à ségou g s'est bougé
depuis les 10 15 dernières années pour
valoriser l'art de la table
l'art l'éco-responsabilité il faut pas
oublier cet aspect laqué important on
n'est pas juste des collecteurs de taxes
pour le gouvernement fédéral ou
provincial
on y met comme tout notre amour sur
notre coeur on est des vitrines pour
l'artisanat local sinon on travaille on
les fait travailler à main si on
travaille pas en effet pas travailler un
nom qui a tous à prendre en
considération
monsieur fait remercier infiniment rien
bon courage avec plaisir à une prochaine